mothers learning how to deal with tear
gas
students blocking the streets
security forces cracking down on every
protest
and families standing in line for
powdered milk
if a government can't feed its own
people then it's useless says this man
the middle classes are trying to
overthrow president nicolas maduro the
upper classes are applauding them but
even poorer venezuelans are discontented
venezuela's mired in confrontation and
stability is not on the horizon over 40
people have been killed on both sides
and each blames the other for the
casualties
they're in power they're operating
outside the law and violating the
constitution that's why the people are
on the streets
do we have to tolerate it when they
attack us do we have to watch as they
set our country alight aguantarnos
gabiarellano is a popular figure in the
well-heeled districts of caracas she's
one of the leaders of the student
protests and believes that maduro's
government has to go but not because
it's socialist
it would be wonderful she says if we had
socialism here hopefully we'll soon have
socialism like they have in chile but we
don't have that here we only have
propaganda instead of real action
gabby planned to finish her doctorate in
history this year but the protests have
taken over
she hardly enjoys a minutes break
spending her days coordinating
demonstrations skype interviews and
student rallies her driver is a
businessman
alejandra benitez has represented
venezuela three times in olympic fencing
she's a committed chavista a supporter
of the socialist president hugo chavez
who died last year
now she backs his chosen successor
nicolas maduro
don't want to accept that
they destroy streets houses they set
schools on fire
we don't think that's the way to build
up a country
if they want changes okay but changes
that destroy changes based on
confrontation that's not real change
alejandra has not experienced the unrest
first hand in her everyday life she has
only read about it in state media
reports
a student's meeting underway at the
technical university gabby announces a
protest on plaza venezuela
and she denounces the biggest problems
facing the nation
inflation
shortages of milk and flour
the world's fifth highest murder rate
corruption and human rights abuses
as always the meeting culminates in a
call for the maduro government to go
gabby believes she was long ago placed
under secret service surveillance and
that she's a potential target of
government-supported paramilitary groups
this award-winning youth center in the
southeast of caracas exemplifies the
chavez ideology
it offers workshops for youth from
impoverished districts spanning music
art and sport
it's open to everyone not just chavistas
but of course it identifies itself as
socialist
it's clear that it's a socialist
collective she says
and what about those who don't share
that ideology
the rally on plaza venezuela has been
banned
gabi stays away she thinks it would be
too risky to make an appearance
the students withdraw to the nearby
central university
one of the protesters is identified as a
chavista and almost lynched
a heated argument follows about whether
the man should receive medical treatment
he's going in the ambulance bring him
here shouts one opposition activist
three broken ribs injuries to the face
and spine a majority insist that he
receive medical treatment but a
surprising number are opposed
not far away a group of chavistas attack
a student from the opposition beat him
up and humiliate him showing just as
little
mercy later shots ring out
the opposition called a press conference
on plaza altamira
gabi accuses the security forces and
armed paramilitary groups of
increasingly using terror tactics
she is also asked about the barbaric
treatment of the chavista at the
university
i wasn't at the university but the video
clearly shows our friend being
mistreated
and that other citizens rescued him and
saved his life she says
we don't want another fatality whether
red green white small large rich or poor
not one more fatality not one more
bullet no more tear gas grenades we want
to live in peace
every afternoon alejandra trains at
central university
our cameras aren't allowed inside the
sports hall
the university is traditionally an
opposition stronghold and alejandra
often has to deal with snubs from her
fellow students
unfortunately not everyone here has a
sporting mentality
some haven't achieved as much as i have
in fencing she says and what i do
bothers them
on top of that politics in venezuela are
deadlocked
if someone wants to interview me they
create hurdles
various permits have to be secured
and that involves going to the
university authorities or other
authorities just to make things
difficult
it is obvious that it's not easy for her
but she says she tries not to let it get
her down
i will continue to fight for people to
live together peacefully she says
despite their different political
beliefs
we should get together and talk to each
other instead of shutting the doors
this standoff must end
the people should sit down at one table
and campaign for peace and harmony
we should all work together for a more
prosperous and better country
i believe in dialogue but also in
freedom and right says gabi it's
difficult to speak to somebody who
oppresses you who persecutes you who
violates the constitution
dialogue is only possible in a
democratic context we are willing to
take part but not with those in charge
there are 42 venezuelans who can no
longer participate in dialogue because
they are dead and it's for them that
we're taking to the streets and
demanding a change of government
after 16 years of the chavez ideology
the fronts have hardened
you rats these people shout
police officers are regularly confronted
with such hatred on the streets
some people go even further using the
widespread support for the protests
among the middle classes as an excuse to
go on the rampage
it does not take long for the state to
respond
gabby is giving an interview at the
independent radio station radio caracas
she has an hour to promote the students
cause
has all means of repression and has
seized all the wealth of the country for
itself
listeners can take part in the
discussion most want to put questions
directly to the opposition they don't
trust the state media
our friend was standing by a barricade
when the cowards from the national guard
came and attacked and beat him but
luckily he could be freed
most callers sympathize with the
students
this one says that she prays daily for
their safety and protection and urges
them to keep on doing what they're doing
the venezuelans and the students don't
believe in a peace like in cuba
there they live in peace but without
freedom and without freedom and justice
says gabi then peace is just an illusion
the church agrees
peace can only follow from truth from
justice and freedom one after the other
that's why we're fighting on the streets
with three olympic games under her belt
alejandra is now preparing for rio 2016
fencing is her sporting passion but her
political heart belongs to hugo chavez
alejandra says he was like a father to
her and that she was like a daughter to
him
when her sporting career is over she
plans to work as a dentist she has
already successfully completed her
studies
and she has a fully equipped dental
practice purchased with the money she
earned as an olympic athlete
it doesn't cross her mind that the
opposition could succeed in overthrowing
the government she believes that the
poor will remain devoted to the
political ideology of chavez and she is
convinced that chavistas will still be
in power five years from now
in the past people didn't want to admit
that they were venezuelan she says today
they're proud and they're willing to
wear the national colors
they have learned how to fight for their
interests for their country for their
ideals
in five years we will be a very
enlightened people who have lived up to
our ideals
part of the population voted for the
chavista says they believed in them but
they were fooled and now they support us
we want to ensure that those in power
pay
dialogue could offer a way out of the
deadlock but neither side has been
serious about it so far
a dialogue with maduro who shoots at us
no chance